18 votos en sebastián piñera acabará su
mandato al frente de la presidencia de
chile la iniciativa de juicio político
por parte de la oposición no sumó el
quórum de dos tercios necesarios en el
senado cada uno de los senadores ustedes
ha visto y senadores se ha podido
expresar así que se termina una etapa en
este proceso de acusación constitucional
en donde se constata que no existían los
votos que exigían la constitución que
son 29 para poder procesar proceder a la
acusación constitucional la oposición
había iniciado el proceso la semana
pasada en la cámara de diputados tras la
aparición del nombre del mandatario en
los papeles de pandora en ellos se
exponía que piñera habría cometido
supuestas irregularidades en la venta
del proyecto minero dominga en 2010 tras
el sobreseimiento del proceso algunos
diputados opositores han lamentado que
la familia del presidente se negara a
declarar ante la comisión yo lamento que
la familia del presidente sus hijos que
le manejan su negocio se haya negado a
estar en la comisión de la cámara
diputado para poder defenderse no dieron
la cara al margen de este juicio la
fiscalía abrió una investigación contra
el presidente pese a un sobre
seguimiento anterior en 2017 sus
abogados aseguran que el mandatario y su
familia sólo fueron inversionistas
pasivos y no vendieron nada durante el
proceso el rechazo del senado llegó tan
solo cinco días antes de las elecciones
que elegirán al sucesor de piñera en la
presidencia de chile